[Music]
getting to cleaner garage it has been
two years that we've lived here now this
place has just been accumulating this
junk
and finally no let's get out purging all
that crap it out especially because you
know we want to make room for people in
this house but you know we've been
working pretty hard if you look at my
upper lip it's all sweaty I think we've
earned a nice decent lunch
Wow you're gonna do clothes there sure
no pizza hand-tossed pizza our favorite
I'm so excited I love eating this that's
why I'm extra excited when to join I was
like hey we want to partner up with you
with another video I don't like yes I
got to eat one piece my mouth just got
so watery that like I kind of took
myself on my own spit yeah anyway I
guess like thanks um I guess I get to
eat more pizza I've never heard of
anyone being so hungry that they choke
on their own but they're salivating so
hard anyway you throw this in the oven
it's complete delicious you know it's my
favorite part about DiGiorno pizza that
it's so much better than delivery I
obviously score true we haven't ordered
delivery and like an entire year I'm
lovin this DiGiorno partnership thank
you
oh my gosh it was so good I was farting
we've been doing this garage thing all
morning but anyway so we've gotten a
laptop this morning as you can see
there's nothing covering this before in
the morning everything was just like
everywhere but it's cramped I know it
was super cramped in here well it still
is we can't fully stand upright so this
whole time that we're cleaning we're
like this so my lower back is killing me
true you're the good little bit quad
works good way to make you feel like
you're really old it's just easier if I
just squat it I don't know what's down
here anymore
it's been a while and all this stuff is
just been like out of sight out of mind
exactly so this is just this part right
over our garage the next part over here
so everything on this side so first of
all we have pixels tank there which
reminds me I don't know if we ever
mentioned it on our channel though we
got rid of pixel like a year ago she was
just a lot of work it was just soul
crushing to feed her every week or every
two weeks so I hit up Gina cos Gina we
were technically pixels foster parents
because Gina couldn't take care of her
so then we took a wall then can took
care of her and then no we took her over
and then so finally more like look do
you know we can't watch her anymore can
you find someone to take care of her
please and as you did
and then they came to pick her up but
they didn't take the tank so we've been
stuck with this tank she's not in there
anymore sometimes I miss her I miss
cuddling with your pixel she was so
sweet and she was very affectionate I
don't think so
you're like David David's like snakes
can't love snakes don't care about you
and I'm like okay he's probably right
but can I just trick myself a little bit
I want to feel loved okay I just judge
snakes by the way they look and the way
their eyes look it's like this they
don't they don't creep up like that yeah
I didn't aim to go oh that's true she
does see that only how do you read that
face that faces looks like the Fred at
her to me that's why yes dear you just
have to trick yourself and tell yourself
that hey love me but anyway behind this
tank is a whole bunch of cardboard we
have so much cardboard that and this is
mainly from when we moved so a lot of
these boxes held like our furniture that
we built our TVs and this is Isaac's old
toddler bed mattress and we just have a
whole bunch of stuff that we need to get
rid of oh yeah so that's for like
storage of things that we actually want
to keep and then that storage of just
all trash like we just need to trash
everything why haven't we trashed it we
are convinced that we can't move Vicki's
boxes that are owned until we get a nice
big fancy SUV in a very big or fancy
truth tree does need an SUV and we can
always ask a friend to borrow it but we
just never want to bother our friends we
just need a big car to get rid of this
cuz we can't move this with our tiny
little cars or we could you know spend
the time and labor to chop everything up
then I rather get an SUV yes oh yeah so
we pulled all these things out and this
is all it's just bags all one big bear
and bags of clothes I need to get rid of
surprise that bear state white so it's
been out down here for a year now you
know where we got that bear frozen
gotten dirty do you even know where that
bears from Joe yep
you remember I guess Joe had this in his
closet for a very long time and he
wanted to get rid of it so he gave it to
Isaac but Isaac was already old and he
was like I don't want that in my room
and then actually I wanted to wash it
like somehow figure out how to wash it
and then give it to take up but then now
they have like four gigantic bears in
their living room so I'm like yeah they
don't want another one so now we just
got to get rid of it you know those
videos we're like YouTube families love
to like cut the teddy bears and then get
in there and they're like although yeah
I'm a family like everyone does it on
YouTube the Isaac vinegar I think they
do bring to us even though we
masterminded and then we're helping him
gut it out and then we can just get rid
of that okay so anyway here's Isaac's
cool project though hey the Hollywood
sign and then there's Chaplin and then
there's Marilyn he did really good I'm
proud of him he got a four outstanding
four out of four and he was four out of
five I don't know he he didn't get a
five how's that out of five I don't know
there's just a lot of stuff here in the
garage but you know what I recently saw
in these two things here there are
photos of my life and I'm gonna show you
here did you grab the camera honey can
you grab it excel in the photos you just
look like a shadow so we don't have to
go back to cleaning yeah I mean we
pretty much finished the cleaning that
meetings organized and we threw trash
away there was a lot more trash in here
that we got rid of true Oh
to the photos I do want to mention you
guys see this right here
as you can tell I'm not I don't like
being very wasteful so ever since
Isaac's baby shower up in saving gift
bags whenever they're given to me and I
use them to give to other people because
I'm like hey this is only been used once
why would I throw it away
so that's what I have in here a bunch of
big bags I've saved over the years and
then I have it organized with occasions
like Christmas or birthday for a girl
break it for a boy or neutral man in
this box and here is some more bag but
this is how organized I love to be where
even the tissue paper I say so I fold
all of the tissue paper and I
color-coordinated so I can easily see
which colors I can use for the bag that
I've saved to gift wrap I'm a genius
guys you should do this and plus it
saves you money and it saves the earth
just a tiny little bit from that one
time that you don't throw it away
yeah very true this is how I know you
love whatever that what do you call that
I don't you know what that is but this
is how I know you love that because what
you're talking about is the way I would
talk about movies I know I get really
excited organizing I don't know anyway
[Applause]
you just bring it down so my back is
killing me I'm swatting already so let's
see what's in here
[Music]
look at me when I was 15 that's my
toilet face and then these are the two
friends that I had in high school
actually I still talk to this one though
isn't that crazy I've known her her name
is Krystal by the way I've known her
since kindergarten
and we're still friends isn't that
amazing
oh look at my brothers my brother's Remy
and Kristian you're so little look at
that that's so cute
you know what's insane Kristian just
turned 18 and Remi is about to turn 20
that blows my mind you guys want to see
a very embarrassing photo this was my
freshman year winter formal who's that
guy his name was absent cuz he passed
away a few years ago condolences I know
it's really sad when I found out he
passed away I was like what that's
insane rest in peace Upton but yeah we
went to Winter Formal together look at
this this baby Tiffany you know I still
somewhere my family ever seen this one
before
really I showed you all these photos we
don't remember I mean yes I do
somewhere and either my position
probably my mom's cuz I remember saying
this but my mom kept this outfit like
pink diapers like raisable diaper thing
the cloth ones and then this shirt I
think it was from birth the way at that
but she actually kept this outfit and
for years I would look at it like oh my
gosh that's all tiny I was and you see
how curly my hair was I had an afro baby
afro look
these are my parents when they used to
be together I was little is that
restaurants all around I don't know I
want to know where the restaurant is
I would love to see it cuz I remember
this restaurant I remember being little
and my dad used to love his restaurant
place to go there all the time the
Mexican see it please thank you look at
these that's Isaac yeah when Isaac was a
baby and I compared my baby photos to
him I'm like dang he looked like me look
how cute I am I'm so cute I'm such a
cutie just kidding I like the fro me too
I wish my hair was that curly still
pretty damaged from all the processing
it's been through oh you guys want to
see me during my bunker rocker phase 14
here I think it was 14 years old I like
the red stripe across the front it looks
like an album cover or sometimes oh look
it here's me being Cristal in high
school that was during her rocker face -
I'm wearing on my shirt
cuz I was like yeah
Spanish rock that was so cool oh and
look at the little seven-year-old
Tiffany I was so excited you know a
movie I'm holding here
let me guess let me guess let me guess
Aladdin oh wow tilda oh I didn't know
that I should have known that and this
is when I got baptized it's crazy looks
crazy like what am I looking at you know
is crazier
you know me looking through all these
photos I have a feeling like have I've
logged this before because I remember
talking about this photo don't you
remember that I wait there's two of you
this was the photo that convinced me
that I was a twin wait what this was and
I remember seeing this in a video one
time comment down below wave if I've
talked about this photo before in a
different video but anyway this photo
convinced me that I was a twin and I was
like distressed with mary-kate and
Ashley to and I was little I had all the
VHS tapes and I asked him like please
you please just tell me like don't have
a sister up there cuz I was like the one
thing I wish I always had it was a
sibling like a sibling that was close to
my age like look you could see our leg
like there's a leg under the other dress
like there's like overlapping cuz I'm
always telling me that was a photo
effect that they just doubled me but I
was like no it's cross see like you
could see like it's like there's just no
way this is not a photo effect so I have
a twin out there so that's that's you
put that you and both oh my mom says
Erin I probably have a twin out there
but it's not a mirror effect though I
don't know you see you see I have a twin
guys and I don't know where she is help
me find her yeah I think it's a photo
effect oh hi
because if you look closely there's like
the darkness over here like it's like
dark and then this photo is cut out but
there were other photos too of where it
looked like one of me was like
transparent this dude who ever took
these photographs it did a pretty good
so they were doing some fancy like photo
techniques before Photoshop but even
though like when I was younger and I saw
that transparent one I was just like no
I know I have a twin out there this
one's cute from the beach day it doesn't
look like you when you have your baby
fat that you really doesn't look like
you early life is parenting how does it
feel to be a parent now and to kind of
feel that full circle feeling you were
talking about this with your mom the
other night well we were relating
because my brother forgot that my mom
did something for him and he thought
that it was somebody else and she was
like you'd remember that was me and I
was like oh my god I go through that
with Isaac all the time he never
remembers me in his memories for some
reason he'll either replace me with
someone else so he'll just completely
forget that we did that together like at
all or like that I taught him something
he'll be like yeah somebody else taught
me that and I'm like that was me why do
you replace me in your memories we got
like we were bonding over that I'm like
yeah I really - now mom like all this
stuff that I put you through
well not all of it because we're still
not in the teenage phase
yeah whoo I know I'm really scared about
that but I'm like yeah that's pretty
cool
that now I can relate to her and I like
it also makes you appreciate your
parents and everything that they went
through for you because you're doing
that for your kid it just makes you see
that the relationship with your parents
have been completely
different perspective once you were
parent yourself cool this was right
before I got pregnant this is a few
months before I got pregnant the life
was about to turn upside down 17-year
old Tiffany
your girlfriend I'm married to that
person that's weird I know is that weird
for you that's right now look at your
baby stuff like oh that's my husband
that's the guy I'm gonna spend for
everywhere but look who okay who is that
stud do you know where we were here we
were in Mexico yep Rosarito
we had lobsters that day remember
actually birth Oh No yes as it is it's
our first trip together yeah though it's
technically a very very first trip I
remember it well was it when you were
telling your parents we're gonna go say
I'm gonna go on a trip I'm going Mexico
being out of the country
really yeah with this girl I just
started dating and and then I thought my
parents were like our trip is a huge
deal you know you go on our trip as soon
as you start dating is a huge deal so
that would kind of play it off well it's
nothing serious which is really hanging
out and if she's gonna go visit some
family but we're just hanging out
nothing too serious in New York that
year I think it was like five months
after we started dating we went to New
York that's pretty crazy
but you know I you tagged along on that
trip I was ready to go by myself you
were gonna go to New York all by
yourself
twenty-three year old girl all your
friends drop out from the trip you're
gonna go fire stuff to the big city and
I'm like well I mean I just started
dating you and I mean jeez I guess I
care about you right now
I can't let you just go to New York by
yourself so it's gotta go with you Who
am I gonna find the go with you and I
just decided I guess I'm gonna be the
guy you're with - I'm gonna go with me
is that what you just said in my mind
that's what I wanted to do I'm like I
don't want to go to New York I'm not
trying to go to New York and all right
you never told me this that's a big trip
it's a big trip with a lot of money and
in the beginning of any relationship you
don't want to spend huge dollar amounts
for someone that you're like I'm not too
sure how far this is gonna go but for
some reason that same trip I also buy
your Tiffany's children
which by the way I was buying myself cuz
that was like something I had always
wanted to do I wanted to go to the
flagship store in New York on Fifth
Avenue and buy on my own so it's gonna
buy these tiffany earrings and then I
turn around or something I remember it
did something and while I was doing
something else you snuck in and you paid
for it so I didn't make you do that you
did that by you and look right now and
then every that started the Tiffany's
arere tradition for like five years or
four years I'm like you gotta stop
please you don't need to buy me
expensive stuff it's just it's okay I'm
okay with just experiences alright so I
think we've had a pretty good break a
little break reminiscent break the
memory lane yeah memory lane break break
breaking down memory lane anyways we're
gonna go back to organizing some boxes
probably deal with all the trash on the
other side and catch you guys later but
like I found another photo of me when I
was in preschool you're a witch they're
what I don't know a witch
I was in the kitchen I was being a wife
you had a cloak and you had a hat on
it's not a cloak it's a pink robe and I
mean I'm opening a carton of eggs I know
what it is it's the orange and black on
the border there gives it like this car
it's a Halloween vibe but this is the
Halloween colors already
[Music]